Hello, my name is Lynn Loxton and I am going to have a
conversation with Amy Rosenfeld for Visible Lives,
An Oral History Project at the New York Public Library. It is
Tuesday, March the 10th, 2015
and this is being recorded at the J.C.C. in New York City.
Welcome Amy, thank you for agreeing to be interviewed. We look forward to hearing your story.
Thank you.
I, um, have had a disability my whole
life. I was born with an [itis called ??]
which, kind of, sort of, affects your vision. It just, kind of, you're born with it.
You can't see it.
And as a child I was diagnosed with dyslexia.
Um, but,
But, I'd like to say that
I don't like it when people say, "Oh, you have a disability." I
don't want to be, um, viewed as somebody who can't do things in society.
Um, everybody, um, needs help. It's OK to get
help, but I feel like, um, I wanna use
my strengths. Um, And
though I know I have some weaknesses, but everybody in life has weaknesses. Nobody's
perfect, um, which I'm glad about. But I'd like to say
that, um, you know, I have my health, but I think
that, um, it's very important
just, um, like for instance, I have a brother on the West Coast
Coast and, uh,
I'm, I'm trying and hoping that he will just
just learn to love me for, uh, who I am, not teach me
not be my mentor, not lecture me, but just learn to love me
love me. Um, and so I wrote a little piece
for [??] adaptations and I write and so I'm going to read it.
Um,
It's called "How to Just Love Your Sibling With Special Needs." If
you're a sibling who has a brother or sister with special needs, just love them. Chances are
are they already get enough help, so just love and do not try to lecture
lecture or teach them. What a sibling can do to love
their older or younger sibling with special needs. Accept them for who
they are. Do not talk down to them. Do not lecture your
your brother or sister. You do not have to be their teacher either.
Spend quality time with them. Go to a museum. Go on a walk or just for coffee.
coffee. Hug your sibling. Sometimes that feels nice, too.
Part of loving your sibling with special needs includes encouraging him or her, and not
being too critical of everything they do.
Because as a child with special needs, one is put down and criticized too much over their
lives. Provide some positive compliments and statements to your sibling
with special needs. Just show them love, a nice note or letter.
Finding out how they are and just to say you love them and are thinking about them.
them. Hug your sibling now and then, just to ask, "How are you?"
Show some compassion and empathy. Just love your sibling,
sibling. No teaching or lecturing. Let your sibling with
special needs shine. Give them their independence,
but be there for them if they need you. Um,
And that's true for anybody who has any kind of
a disability. That's true for anybody out there. Uh,
you know, chances are, that person with special needs gets enough help.
So family and friends should just abide by what I read.
And, and, I really feel like
society looks down too much on people with disabilities.
Not all disabilities can be seen.
I hurt my foot five years ago. So for me,
me it's hard to stand on the bus, so I ask for a seat,
and sometimes I ask the bus driver for the lift if it's
an older bus, and they look at me and they say "You don't have
a wheelchair. You don't have crutches," and I go, "But
I'm not good with stairs and I need the lift." And they
say, "Oh but you don't have a wheelchair," and I
say, "But I need the lift." And then sometimes I ask for the ramp.
Some bus drivers don't want to put out their ramp either.
I always get off on the newer buses in the front of the bus because it's lower down.
Um, I don't use subways,
um, a few too many stairs for me.
I feel safer above ground right now.
Um. At some point that might change.
I'm not sure. Um, and I
I'd just like to say, though, that here at the J.C.C.
everyone's accepted for who they are. I'm accepted for who I am
in my workplace and also in the building and all the
programs I go to.
It's not, "Oh you have a disability. You can't work here. You have a
disability." If you're not seen as a person with a disability.
And, but, there are programs for people with special needs, which I'm part of,
Adaptations, um, and I go to a lot of their programs,
Um, And it's a good support. It's a very, very good
good support. And I've managed to find my own
own help. It's my own resources,
and I feel very good about that. But I really, really honestly feel
like, um, some
disabilities are visible and some are not. And mine is not visible.
Um. So I think it's important that society be
aware of that. Um, you know, sometimes I'm slower on
stairs, sometimes I'm slower to get off the bus, um, but I
I do it. That's the important thing, is that I do it. And
I just feel like people need to be aware, um, about people with
disabilities and not, um, and just realize that
everybody has a full potential in society and
everybody, um, just tries their best
and, ah, they shouldn't be, ah, denied a job because of a
disability. Um, they shouldn't be denied housing
or uh medical care because of a disability. Everybody has the same rights.
Um, and if this is one thing that comes from this interview, that's very
very important. Is it everybody?
We have the same rights and to be given a chance in society at what they want to do.
do. Um, I'm sure there are doctors out there with disabilities. Um, I'm sure there are surgeons
out there with disabilities. Um, I'm sure there are teachers and
lawyers, um, with disabilities. Society
is a good mix of everyone and we need to keep that in mind.
And I hope that this is helpful. So
I think I've said my share and I hope I've made a good impression.
You've done remarkably well. Could you just tell us a little more
about what the Adaptations program does here at J.C.C.
because this is going to be archived and in years to come people
may want to look back and see what some of the kinds of programs are because
this is such an enormous community resource itself.
Great, sure, [yes] my pleasure. Um, Adaptations here at the J.C.C. of Manhattan
is a program for people in, um, their 20s and 30s and beyond.
Um, It's a program that offers a different kind
kind of groups. Um, I go to a drama group one night a
week where we talk, where we do improv and we do acting
about our feelings and we, um, in the beginning of drama group we
always express ourselves, um, by going around the circle with a sound and a movement about how
we're feeling. Um, lit club. Um, we
write creatively and the piece I've read about how to just love a sibling with special
needs, um, came
came to me just because of, you know, what's going on, [sure] you know, with my family and
also just to make a statement because I think a lot of people just feel that way in general.
Um, So we write creatively and then we share, or, we, people who want to share can
share, and people who don't feel like sharing don't need to share.
Um,
There's a whole, there's an art group that meets. There is a
a, um, ah,
a game night, a movie night. So you can sign up for what you want to sign up for.
for. Um, a lot, a lot of times after the groups we go
out for a bite to eat so we make connections outside of groups. Lot of the times we meet up and go to
movies. Um,
There's a whole, whole
list of activities that goes on and on. Um, I go to,
there's lounge on Sundays, in the afternoon there's lounge where you can hang out and
pictures and write games and make friends and learn how to interact.
And learn social skills. Um, actually the drama group used to be
called Creative Alternatives of New York, and this year it's Creative
called Creative Alternatives to Social Learning, [good] so we do drama around
social skills, um, that will help us in society.
We did a whole thing on family and friendships and dating
now we're going to be talking about boundaries [m hm] um, and who knows
where that will lead to. Um, and there's another group that I'm part of.
It is called Y.A.I. The Young Adult adult
Institute for people with disabilities. That's in Midtown on 34th
Street. And I go to a good group called Hankering for More. It
meets once a month, depending on what group you're in.
About once a month or once every five weeks. And you, there's
usually a lunch involved with a trip.
Um, to a museum, so you either do a museum and lunch and lunch and a museum.
Movie and lunch. Sometimes you meet at Y.A.I.
and um, there was once a meditation and yoga
event. And the people who lead the Y.A.I.
program got me, um, hooked up with their gallery and
I'm an artist and I express myself a lot through art. Um,
I've been studying at the Art Students League for 15 years and I call it
art therapy. It relaxes me. I love it.
And it's my other passion.
I tend,
So, they got me, the Hankering for More people hooked me up with the gallery
and we exhibit, and we sell our work sometimes,
And there's a big fundraiser this week. But anyway, it feels so
so good for an artist to sell their work.
And as a gallery, the artists get back sixty percent of the
sale price. Uh,
It's not a million dollars, it's not in the Louvre or the MOMA, but it's a very,
very good feeling, and it gives you a sense of
self-worth, as does having a job in society. It gives you a sense
of self worth. Um, and it makes you feel
"Hey, I'm an Artist. I'm not in a museum
but I sold and I sold a few pieces." And I think
to end, I'm gonna re-read "How to love a sibling with special needs."
What a sibling can do to love their
older or younger sibling with special needs: accept them for who they
are. Do not talk down to them. Do not lecture your
sister or brother. You do not have to be their teacher either.
Spend quality time with your sibling. Go to a museum, on a
walk or just chat over coffee. Hug your sibling. Sometimes
that feels nice too. Part of loving your sibling with special needs
Includes encouraging him or her and not being too critical
of everything they do. Because as a child with special needs
one is put down and criticized too much throughout their lives.
Provide some common positive compliments and statements to your
sibling with special needs. Just show them love, a nice note or
letter. Finding out how they are and just to say you love them and are
thinking about them. Call your sibling now and then just
ask "how are you." Show some compassion and empathy.
Just love your sibling, no teaching or lecturing. Let your
sibling with special needs shine. Give them independence but
Be there for them if they need you.
Thank you so much. Thank you Amy, this has been really a wonderful presentation.
Thank you very much. Thank you my
pleasure.